I don't think I'm a feminist because I
do believe that I am strong on that
gender roles I don't really identify
with anything that feminism stands for
anymore a woman's purpose is to nurture
and reproduce as well as I'm concerned
you guys know women that can sleep
around and are genuinely happy doing it
I feel like we should be asking you what
are you bringing to the table maybe
because of my past experiences where I
am now I don't want to be with someone
that's going to come up if you consider
yourself a feminist um yes no and then
why
um I'd say no
I'm not a feminist because
I think I believe
I'm in between I would say but I'll say
no because I don't think
there's things that men can do and
there's things that women can't do and
there's things that women can do and
there's things that men can't do if that
makes sense so I feel that's why
I'm in the middle and I'm still seeing a
bit of nah I'm not a feminist
okay
um yeah me I'm I'm similar to Janae
um I don't think I'm a feminist because
I do believe that I am like strong on
like gender roles
um so I do believe that um there's
certain things that a woman should do in
a relationship there's certain things
that man should do in a relationship but
I'm also that big on women empowerment I
just don't feel like it collides yeah
okay go ahead I would say no
um I don't really identify with anything
that feminism stands for anymore
okay go ahead
um yeah I'm sort of like in between I I
would say I'm very much a traditional
feminist
um not so much a modern feminist
um I still have those Traditional Values
and I feel like I do believe in female
empowerment I do believe in the movement
of feminism
um yeah
okay go ahead yeah I would say I'm sort
of in between as well
but it just gets a bit too technical I
believe in them obviously opening doors
for women but it gets too technical for
me so for me I'm in between as well this
feminists role okay
I do not consider myself to be a
feminist whatsoever a man and a woman
has complete different duties and roles
they're not equal a man's purpose is to
protect provide hunt and lead and a
woman's purpose is to nurture and
reproduce as far as I'm concerned they
are not equal
I'm not a feminist I'm very in tune with
myself spiritually
and I feel like everything in the modern
day world just really collides with my
spirit so definitely not
wow a whole room not one feminist wow
why do you guys think that is where has
it gone too far
please promiscuity is promoted I think
that's too far I think
for women having multiple sexual
partners is really bad for your mental
health
um it messes up your hormones
biologically
and also like even if you're not
technically sleeping with all of them
what kind of person are you if you're
just an object on millions of people's
screens and all that object is is
your boobs and bum they're not really
seeing you for who you are and if you
don't care about who you are enough to
put that out there and all you want to
put out there is your body
um then I think that shows that maybe
there's something not quite right inside
that maybe you don't value in yourself
so you only value the exterior part of
yourself do you guys know women that can
sleep around and are genuinely happy
doing it no I don't think I've ever met
one really no
no one no so why do you think it's
pushed so much if the outcomes aren't
good for women
because I feel like people
that people that maybe
um this is just that from me watching
but I feel like people that maybe do
sleep around a lot
um maybe if they don't actually like
know who they are or like know what they
stand for completely and they want to
act like they're happy so they'll tell
people yeah this is what makes me happy
this is what I do so you do it too so
it's like less it's like some whole gang
thing
um like even Amber Rose for example this
what is that thing she does a nude
walks yeah
would anyone go to a walk anyone
here no okay okay yeah I'll go no I
can't lie I would go for fun like to
watch it I would do interviews yeah
I don't think I would take part in a sub
walk no yeah definitely no how do you
think so but yeah what I was going to
say about the Amber Rose
um suck walk I feel like with feminism
now it's if you show your the more body
you show the more empowered you are as a
woman and I feel like there's so much
more to that and it's like they try and
talk for all women as a whole when
really this is your opinion so even in
dating now it's like men they'll come
and talk to you in a certain way like
you're a feminist already like they just
think you're a feminist I don't know I
don't say explain it but yeah do you
think older women sabotage younger women
yeah yeah
yeah I I feel like going back to what we
were just talking about as well like I
feel like women are trying to compete
with men and I think that is literally
where the problem is we are trying to
compete with men why is it okay for a
man to sleep with loads of women but
it's not okay for me and actually do we
actually enjoy that like we have to
actually ask so ask ourselves like do we
actually enjoy
casually giving our body like that and
you know because we have emotions and we
you know we feel things and like for men
it's different they can go and do that
and have zero emotion whereas with women
it's completely different and we can't
you know deny that so is it though like
do you actually think like do you
actually well most of my friends I feel
like you know they tell me stories and
they sleep with someone and they get
attached like so you don't think men do
or do you think they're just better
hiding their emotions because they don't
no they don't they don't think so no I I
meant to go and do that and have zero
emotion they can do that and and they're
programmed to be like that whereas why
are we trying to compete with that but
but just because someone's programmed to
be like something I don't feel like
they're being completely open and saying
like they can just go and sleep around
with anyone and they don't feel any like
I don't believe that I actually don't I
don't think they've got to the root of
the problem of why they can't do that
because that's not Humane but the thing
is like when money is money power and
Status they do do it so it's like yeah
it's a trend for a month is Chris Brown
like saying stops no
don't sleep with me of course they're
loving it but I feel like there's
effects that is just it's not attached
to okay you're seeking with loads of
people this is why you feel like that I
feel like they might feel type of ways
but they're not attaching it to all
because I'm just going around sleeping
with loads of women because I've got
loads of male friends and I see the
after effect that it has with them
sleeping with loads of women but they
weren't actually I don't know yeah they
were actually admitting or pinpoint it
on that but I think that sort of goes
back uh that sort of goes back to like
the whole peer pressure with men and
maintaining this image of like you know
when you become successful and you have
money those will come with it and I feel
like a lot of men are trying to force
that and that's probably why your
friends are feeling some type of way
afterwards because they're doing
something but maybe they don't really
want to be doing it but also I'll be
real like
when men obviously see Paran their
body's not going to change if a woman
sleeps around your body's a temper your
body is going to change it's going to
adapt to whoever you're sleeping with so
that's great where you know I mean I'm
saying like Okay the levels of women and
men financially are like the same but
like Following being full of fashion
like it's like
yo the mean like you're lowering your
standards and your body changes that
women we're very reward that to a man
well not me but you know what I'm saying
as for men they just you know I mean
they can go around do what they do in
hunky dory their body's not going to
change a woman's body does change you
know what I mean you're a key so yeah
very true yeah very true and I feel like
as women we we just have a lot more to
lose and that there's a lot more at
stake for us so that's why we are
naturally gonna be very you know picky
and selective and
you know I I pride myself in being
selective and you know not giving my
body freely to just anyone like
do you think you guys could respect a
guy
um and follow his lead if you make more
money than him
[Music]
um
no I don't mind like in terms of
finances it doesn't make a difference to
me yeah I wouldn't mind if my partner
made more money than me it's as long as
you talk to me with the same level as
respect because I'm still earning so
what if you were paying 80 of the bills
and you had to buy a house so let's say
you pay that don't mean yeah that's it
that's it I'm just taking it to the ex
like to the extreme you're paying 80 of
the bills and he says we're buying this
house and you don't like it you hate it
are you gonna go with it no yeah you'd
have to convince me why we're buying it
you have to make logical sense I
personally I think that's the the whole
point is that you're not submitting if
he has to convince you sure that's like
if it's your boss and he tells you to do
something you just do it right so it's I
mean I think when we're being honest
it's hard to submit to someone if they
don't make more money and I feel like a
man is meant to be if you're married
provider we're not Sole Provider but the
a provider and I don't feel like if
you're not earning more than me you
could provide for me enough like fully
and if we're buying a house together and
I don't like it I'm not going and I'm
providing basically more it's going to
be more my decision I think it'd be hard
for me to submit to someone who isn't
basically being able to lead me you're
gonna have to be able to lead me and if
you're not earning more than me it's
going to be harder for me to agree or
listen to you it might sound oh that's
not nice but that's how I feel I can't
listen to someone that
isn't earning more than me but why is
that the world I just feel like it's
just because of the way I've been raised
if I for example I use my dad he's
always earned he's always been an earner
he's always been able to look after me
and his family so that's what I see my
future husband doing and if you're not
earning more than me maybe if it's a
short period of time you've you've lost
money or you're down but I couldn't
marry someone that earns less than me I
just couldn't because how I see the role
of a man in a household you're meant to
be a leader provider I just couldn't
well I don't understand sometimes
there's a come up so they might be low
yeah beginning would could you stick by
someone that has a good heart and be
with them through to come up
to be honest with you I thought maybe
because of my past experiences
um I I where I am now I don't want to be
with someone that's on a camera
um I feel like
especially because I have a child and
where I want to be in life I don't want
someone that's going to come up uh maybe
a few years ago it was fine but where I
am now I want you to be at least a
certain level earn a certain amount of
money consistently I don't want to have
to raise your support you consistently
how much money is it how much money do
you know what it doesn't have to be a
large amount of money because I'm not
like what's the word high maintenance or
let me Google hold on yeah it just
average average salary UK
okay you want everything I feel like
someone just be able to live maintain be
able to go out on events and do things
it doesn't have to be crazy but as long
as you're London 41 000 pounds if he
earns that yeah that's the average says
the average yearly wage for full-time
workers in London in 2022 according to
status
yeah I think that would be fine for me I
don't you don't have to be a millionaire
or billionaire no way you just have to
be able to support yourself so that we
can rise together I don't want someone
that's down and then I have to pull you
up because I've got a child I don't have
time to be pulling up everyone then
there's rebuttal is what are you
bringing to the table well my bringing
to the table I don't get myself well I'm
bringing myself
I can do yeah but yeah I bring a lot to
the table why do you hate the question I
hate that question but it's like if
you're interviewing for a job you have
to show them your resume yeah experience
yeah yeah of course but I feel like when
men ask that question
I feel like we should be asking you what
are you bringing to the table because
I've had dinner you want bags you know
what's nice yeah but you're forgetting a
woman is going to first of all she's
going to make your house
she is going to raise your kids most
modern women can make a house a home do
those modern women have recipes from
scratch no no not modern women
they're tick tock not necessarily
not necessarily but what I mean is she
is going to make your house feel like a
home she is going to be there for you
specifically
well you would you would do duties
around the house but not every woman
does that now it's a certain type of
woman you're talking about so like what
I mean personally that a hooker a cook
and a cleaner can't do but she's gonna
be providing you with support
emotionally but I just thought like when
men hear this it's like it's like we're
saying nothing oh okay it's like not
like it's not specific as I can do this
I have the skill this this and this my
mama can do that do you know what it is
obviously there's a lot of my sexuality
and my role is basically like the
Melrose so that's why I'm just asking
these little ones and twos to throw you
off but also to get a better
understanding but I don't really hearing
it's not matching up to the 41. I don't
forget why everything's always centered
around finances I understand you need
money to survive but I don't understand
where women have the high expectations
of expecting a man to have so much money
to get with him like how can I thought
like if you love someone it's based on
love like not just based on what you can
pick like like you can take all these
boxes but where's the love in that um
I'll get it one thing I realized from
being in a relationship love is not
enough love is not so you can love life
it's great to be in love but it's not in
everything peace and love is life I okay
we can say that a man wants peace when
you think about it and he wants love you
can be in love with someone love them
dearly but when the bills come is that
love gonna pay you need to lower your
maintenance then you've got your high
expectations you should be providing for
yourself and you can't expect the man to
do that no but yeah for example okay you
live together there's certain things
that a woman May pay and there's certain
things that a man May pay okay you both
work love is not going to pay those
bills love is not going to keep you
woman what you enjoy when you survive
the life of a household together you
survive that's how it works I mean you
become accustomed to the wealth that you
make in your household I get that but
that's that's not the way I would want
to live my life yeah to be able to enjoy
I want to be in love and be able to say
okay so if your man makes more more than
you why should why is he expected to
make more and you make less and you both
live the same he doesn't have to make
more he just said he has to make more
didn't you no no I didn't say he has to
make more I said if I made more I
wouldn't be able to submit to him he's
going to make so he has to make more we
could make the same amount we'd be happy
with the same amount yeah I'd be happy
with the same amount but I find I'll
know if he makes
less than me it would be harder for me
to submit because I just I just that's
how I see it I can't even put a nail on
it but I know if a man-made left you
think Society has a role to play in that
that finances got taken 100
yeah part of me it's taken do you think
Society has taken a toll on how you love
someone because it's supposed to be love
yeah um no I think it's just the way I
see love I feel like love is not enough
maybe love is based on material then
basically no what I think love is is you
can love someone but maybe uh what can I
say so say you was with a man and he was
rich and then he went broke would you
stay with him 100 because what's the
difference there the difference is
because you've gone broke I didn't meet
you bro why can't you help somebody get
rich if you can help them stay bro yeah
because it's a mentality thing if he
could get rich in the first place then I
know in my heart he can get rich again I
believe I believe a good man I know it
is personally I get what you're trying
to say a good person can see potential
in somebody from nothing the problem is
if I speak for my personal experiences I
am always the one seeing potential in
people and always maybe there's
something that you should look within
yourself that might need fixing when
choosing a partner then maybe it's not
the man maybe you know what it is maybe
it is but that's why I've made a
decision to say I'm not looking I'm not
going to go with somebody that is I'm
not going to look at anyone's potential
anymore because we can see potential for
days it doesn't mean that they're going
to reach that so what I've learned is I
now want to be with someone or get to
date someone that is at a certain stage
that I can say okay you're not you're
pulling up stage I don't have to pull
you up I think that's very unfair on men
well maybe that is but that's my opinion
that's where I am now I've given people
chances pull them up you want a high
value man I wouldn't say high value but
someone that is a high value yeah
because it's a high value but you've got
a child as well yes you guys know yeah
if we're going to use that term it's 10K
a month that's the time now yeah
I wouldn't say high value I just want
someone that is able to pay their bills
feed themselves okay so what if a guy
ticked all them boxes and emotionally
you don't feel nothing but besides that
it's absolutely perfect would you stay I
don't like him like there's no emotional
connection there's no love there you
said love isn't what you used to be so
no I said love isn't enough so I can
love someone but everything else has you
have to be respectful you have to have
to say take to all them boxes yeah but
you love them a little bit
um
love is important he takes all them
boxes what I think the question was that
if if a man ticked all the boxes yeah
and you loved him a little bit is that
good enough
no okay no it's not do you I agree with
you sorry do you think there's a minimum
that like a guy has to have a job right
okay yeah yeah I mean I think I think
it's dishonest when we say It's All
About Love because I think at some point
if a guy's unemployed for five years
you're probably gonna leave I think it's
about the mentality of a person so like
if somebody's broke if I say I met
someone and he's broke but he's got the
right mentality to conquer the world I
mean by all means I can support him and
I can help him I'm happy to do that no I
I agree with you it's about mentality
but I just think when we're asking these
questions it's like what what is the
minimum
I don't have a moment if I if I like
somebody and I believe in them then they
got my support but how long how long are
you believing in them until they like as
long as I think it's difficult say I
have money and the man doesn't have any
money if he can respect my values and
like believe that I'm putting him in
positions to help him then
I'll support how long if he's getting
off every day at six in the morning and
he's trying and trying you can't fault
somebody like that
I think I've got a whole different
perspective of life because of myself my
lifestyle and how I've been brought up
like what's different about your
lifestyle everything I think my life
upbringing experience is completely
different to a lot of people okay so I
don't really want to dig too deep on him
even being honest but I just do believe
that my circumstances are quite unique
I just don't think money is everything
so what would it take for you not to
believe in him anymore for you to say
okay call my first like perspective of
this man was wrong and he's actually a
like not a bum sorry Bob if he's
behaving like a bum then obviously
that's a huge red red flag that he
doesn't really want to change his life
he's quite happy being mediocre so yeah
so that's when you'll leave when you
realize his true mentality yeah but I
haven't ever encountered a situation
like that too
say I'm going like okay what were you
gonna say you had something to say
earlier yeah I I just um agree with you
sorry I forgot you're lucky though Janae
um I agree with you and I feel like what
you were trying to say was
yes your love is you love someone but
it's as a woman it's
conditional and I'm gonna be honest as a
woman like my love is conditional yes I
can love you and yes I can have these
amazing beautiful memories with you but
if you are not bringing those qualities
that I want and you are not going to
contribute to the life that I want for
myself then that love is not enough for
me it's not enough for me and if I'm
honest with you I'm not really looking
to be with someone and do the whole
struggle of things yeah I'll be honest
I'm not I'll agree yes if you have
dreams but it's not my job to sit here
and motivate you and be holding your
hand while you're doing it I'm not
looking for a project I'm looking for
someone who is established because I
feel like as a high value woman I am
allowed to seek a high value man
especially because I know what I bring
to the table so I want someone to match
that can you define a high value woman
to me or to you
um I value woman is someone who first of
all has a lot of respect for herself you
know
um has a lot of like Pride you know
works hard men want prideful hard
workers
hmm
well I I feel like no because men
obviously just want someone who's
beautiful and is just gonna be
submissive and say yes and well that's
at least what we're being told but I
feel like I think that's not true
no men don't like submissive women no I
don't think so no because I feel like
it's not about being submissive you just
have to be kind and you have to be
loving and you have to respect your man
a lot of women don't actually respect
their men yes they like them they're
attracted to them they love them but
they don't actually respect them and I
feel like men want respect from women
and they don't get that enough well I I
agree with you but why is that not
submission why isn't that part of
submission
no because I still have a voice you
don't think submissive women have voices
I don't know I feel like if I'm just
going to be saying yes to everything and
doing everything that my man wants then
I've kind of lost sense of who I am like
I want to have a voice in this
partnership I want to have a voice in
this marriage and I want to be heard and
I want to be seen it's a mission it's
like he's your boss so your boss can
take your opinion into account but at
the end of the day Here's the final say
and men don't they don't feel like
they're respected if you don't give them
the final say like they don't want a
woman that they have to argue with all
the time yeah but you don't have to
argue with a man to get your point
across if you're with a loving
respectful man who hears you and values
you he's always going to listen to you
he can he can hear you and listen to you
and still tell you no
okay like so that just because if he
tells me no
it it depends like there's there's
certain things that yeah I might be like
okay cool I'll submit to you because I
would say I'm definitely a traditional
woman and there are you a virgin
I'm sorry I'm saying how are you a
traditional woman is a 22 year old
virgin no as in I have like Traditional
Values the way that I was brought I'm
Arab I'm Moroccan we are brought up in a
certain way
um and the men that I see in my culture
are very traditional they're providers
you know they go out they make money and
a lot of women in my culture they don't
work they just sort of stay at home and
the man goes out and gets the money and
they just raise the kids obviously we've
moved on from that but I still hold
those values in the sense that I'm okay
to submit to my man when the time is
right or when I feel the time is right
but the whole point is that's that's not
submission is when you feel I mean we're
women we change our opinions every
goddamn day we don't even know what we
want half the time so it's like if you
if if I if I employ blessing and I say
blessing turn this camera angle on or I
do do this do this and at the end of the
day I have the final say and and that's
kind of how it is should be anyways when
you're submitting to a guy
so so you're saying that's what men want
they just want someone to go yes I'll do
exactly what you tell me to do no they
just want to argue all the time with
every decision
I'm kidding
I know they just want to fight every day
I personally think they're gonna have
long conversations about every decisions
and just really make you feel heard
wow I feel like yeah I don't know I I
will submit to the right man and if I
feel comfortable but I will always have
my boundaries set in place sometimes
you're not going to feel comfortable I
mean in a 30 40 50 year marriage you
think you're not going to feel
comfortable
and sometimes you're going to feel like
he's not the right man I mean every day
yeah 100 so tell me more about the high
value woman what else
I mean the high value woman is like
someone who like is kind who's nurturing
you know
um who's gonna support her man lift him
up motivate him Inspire him
um
you know is is fun she has that feminine
energy that men crave
um you know the list goes on and I know
that men are not stupid they know when
they come across a high value woman they
know
um so yeah do you want to know what I
hear when I hear higher value woman oh
God designer
she won all that Instagram like
highlighted Factor like Valentine's Day
you better make sure that like you've
got a hotel with the little petals and
the balloons like holidays it's like
it's like give me everything
I mean you know what I mean
to me what I'm hearing when I'm here
they read why a maintenance woman is
it's money in it you need money for that
it's like it's like whenever I hear that
I think of the book why men love
it's like they read that book and then
it's like that's the whole I'm not
saying personally it's just that's
always what I hear
um okay so what percent of the financial
family load do you guys expect to pay to
carry for a lifetime
ten percent
ten percent ten percent okay
um yeah I would say ten percent
ten percent
I think it changes I think it's like
situational I mean
ideally like
maybe 40
um but I think it changes like you never
know what's gonna happen the man might
suddenly go unemployed so you know I'm
gonna have to pick up extra shifts here
and there and then I might go unemployed
or go on maternity leave and and the
man's gonna take over I think it
fluctuates depending on the situation
um yeah I'm kind of the same there as
well
um I also like as you said like
maternity leave or if I if the man said
that he wanted me to be a housewife
which I don't think I would ever like
take up to do but if he did then I'd
expect him to do 100 then I'll be doing
the cookie and I'll be doing the
cleaning but if like I'm working he's
working like I don't expect him to say
that I'm gonna be a complete housewife
because there's some men that like 12
percent
I don't know zero percent depending okay
so you think he should carry a hundred
percent of the bills
no that's not true I don't think so I
think I'm just using it okay if I'm
cooking a cleaner 50 50. okay you okay
so we went from 100 to 50 50. no
depending okay what does it depend on if
I'm working or if I'm not okay do you
want to work or do you not I do
um okay so I would say 50 50. yeah
yeah I I don't I can't think of a
percent
I actually can't been yeah I don't know
are we considering that there's kids
involved here yeah yeah are you sure I
mean unless unless you don't I feel like
I want to change my answer now yeah yeah
same I don't know
I don't know what percent all right I'm
just gonna say numbers raise your hand
is there a wide camera do we have one
difficult
that was for I think it's Dependable on
the circumstances though because like if
if you're green that you stay at home
like if I'm staying at home then well
I'm asking if you if you're zero percent
if I'm at home
um
I've had been with my partner and I've
been at home like he wants me at home so
I can't go to work so he's provided for
me all 100 because obviously it's
impossible if I'm a stay-at-home mom but
if she's working
um I think it should be the percentage
should be agreed like in terms of if
they're making the same then I don't see
why it shouldn't be 50 50 if they're
both aren't working
okay
um all right so 50 50. if she's working
yeah if do you want to work honestly I
like staying at home I'm a home person
okay if I wasn't enough okay so ideally
zero percent yeah I'm raising the kids
okay and you said 10 10 yeah
50 50 for me unfortunately you know I
mean that's what I'm looking for 50 50.
okay yeah I would say 10 like if I'm
working but if I'm not working then
nothing
if you're working 10 percent
yeah okay
I think I'm gonna change it a little bit
like in an Ideal World
I would want to be able to go out and do
something part-time to at least
contribute a bit so I'm going to say 20
20 okay
of I think 70 30 dollars to be honest
it's a good one
um go ahead
yeah I'm still I don't know sorry can't
give a percent what percent of women do
you think get to contribute 20 or less
to the family financial load
the ones that own the home
can you say that again what percent of
women do you think get to contribute 20
or less to the Family Feud not five
percent Housewives I know what percent
of women do you think get to be
Housewives
yeah not a lot in the UK or what is it I
mean the way that the UK is right now uh
probably under 10
you guys feel like you're in the top 20
of women to earn that no
what to be able to be a housewife
my circumstances I believe are
exceptional so I don't believe I've been
a housewife and I've lost my partner so
I was a housewife and I feel like my
perspective of life has changed now that
I have the role of a man in a sense
because I have to provide for my child
so I'm definitely not I'm in tune with
reality hold my position
I'm on the opposite Spectrum so I've
always been the provider and I've got a
little one as well 13 year old so I've
always been the opposite
I've always earned and if I've got in a
relationship I look after
you know what I mean so
yeah it's kind of mad right now me
hearing all these percentages I'm not
even gonna lie
[Music]
okay what about you top 20 of women
uh
I would just say they'll just have to be
Housewives literally are you top 20 of
women yeah I would be qualified to be a
house okay
take all the boxes
top 20 of women yes or no yeah
absolutely yeah
um and you said no
um no no
no big up you look man no yeah no but I
think I've been a housewife I might be a
bit bored yeah
our values qualify or do we want to can
you say which one that's what are you
asking us no I was asking if you think
you're in the top 20 of women
in the eyes of men in the eyes of men
but to be fair with the numbers you'd
always screaming out you sort of are in
it if you wanted to pay 20 you know
in an Ideal World I'd want to pay 20 but
we don't live in an ideal world we live
in the real world and I'm not ignorant
to the fact that I'm not in the top 20
of women so I don't expect to be a
stay-at-home housewife and have things
how I want
um I don't know where people get the
idea that life's supposed to be exactly
how you want it life is how it is and
you deal with it how you're supposed to
given your circumstances my
circumstances are I'm not top 20 so I'm
probably going to be working
what age do you guys think traditional
women get married by
[Music]
maybe 21 between 21 and yeah before
you're 20 100 so like maybe 19 to 24 25
I would say 20.
yeah
well I would say between the age of 21
and 25 21 and 25
25. okay yeah I would have said 25. who
do you guys think benefits more from the
institution of marriage in 2023 men or
women women
yo
no but I don't think it's just money
like I feel like it's like but it's the
institution of marriage not the not the
values of marriage the institution and
women benefit from the institution
massively well I think normally the men
that like earn a lot of money and
they're like the main Breadwinners
sometimes like
um it will end with a lot of domestic
like violence and stuff because they
feel like they're I think that's a bold
assumption okay cool yeah that is a
broad assumption let me just shut up
but still no but I feel like sometimes
like men that make a lot of money they
have a lot more entitlement though I
think it's definitely it doesn't equate
domestic violence no not domestic
violence but like I mean what do you
mean by entitlement
because they think okay I'm the man
you're the woman I'm earning money and
you're not so whatever I say like goes
it's not a thing where it's like rolls
where it's like okay cool I can respect
that you're cooking and cleaning it's
more of a thing where I'm making the
money and that's that's you know we are
harder but we all just said that we
would have a hard time respecting
someone if we made more money than them
when it comes to decision making so
don't you think if he's paying all the
bills he should have the final say in
decision making yes otherwise go find a
guy to split it 50 50 with yeah no I
feel like he should have the final like
but at the same time as you said before
I feel like there still needs to be a
conversation Andrew if you're my in the
right man you'll submit to him and yeah
there should still be and he'll get the
final say but I feel like a lot of men
that are earning they'll just last thing
I have a question
do you want to have a conversation with
your girl about every decision you guys
make nope
but guys don't want to do it and it's
kind of like if a dude's providing a
lifestyle where you get to be in the top
20.
important decision he can consult you
and I think if you're with a guy for
long enough he's going to consult you
maybe but he also might not it's like
the bosses you know like a boss might go
to their best employee and ask their
opinion but at the end of the day who's
whose decision is it
um
and then the employee doesn't go to the
boss and say you need to have a
conversation with me
okay but you keep doing the employee and
boss I think it's very like different a
relationship yeah I mean I agree I mean
it's different but it's the same
principle it's the concept yeah
I get what you mean I I understand what
you mean like if if that's the lifestyle
that we want we have to kind of be
willing to accept what it comes with but
who says that it has to come with
control and like having to obey someone
I don't like that idea like yes he's
providing this life for me but he's also
providing this life for his kids as well
you know and I'm sure he's the man yeah
the man that make the money say that no
I'm I'm saying that he is obviously
providing for his family so some men are
actually happy doing that they actually
want their wife to stay at home and
spend time with their kids and not it's
not a bad thing I'm not I'm not hating
on anyone for wanting wanting what they
want but but what does he get in return
and those guys typically want submission
in return and submission is and we have
to have a conversation every time I want
to
I think women are kind of confused in a
sense like you've got the modern woman
who wants to say traditionally like how
she is with in her views but like it's
contradiction it's contradiction
contradicting it
um both values because she wants to be a
stay-at-home mom but she still wants to
have a say in the household and fight
for the equality with the confusion of
the feminism thing okay it's like a
challenge sorry let me just jump in
there quickly so for example if
something happens with your kids
um there was an issue in the house
um and for example you and your husband
did not agree on the way that that
situation was dealt with
um am I not allowed to have a say as as
the wife as the mother of that child
yeah or do I just listen to my husband
no matter what he says even though I
feel that what he's saying is wrong and
the way that he treated our son or the
way that he decided to deal with that
situation it feels like what you're
doing is wrong you both feel that way
okay but then we have to come to some
kind of agreement because that's but
feelings are temporary feelings aren't
really I just think women are
emotionally with their kids and I'm fine
men very logical and it's factual that a
man would raise his child better than a
woman so I think you have to have faith
in your partner and if he's a man you
have to give him that step above to say
you know what you're the man of the
household if you don't have that the
whole structure of the household doesn't
have any foundations really because a
woman can't run it it's impossible and
it's a statistics say that women are
single parent households and things like
that are really awful for children so I
think you'd have to give your man the
upper hand at some point there's no
equality in the household there's the
man's role in a woman's role that's what
I believe
and the women and the women that
honestly do lead their households are
miserable yeah I mean you you guys see
the girls that wear the pants in the
relationship do they look happy
that's stressed yeah
but oh oh gosh I have a question all
right let's say we go back to the
beginning of feminism with the suffrage
movement if you had to fight if you're
options in order to vote was to fight in
the front line of combat would you give
it up
during war times no nope say the
question again please okay so if
in order to vote you had to be drafted
and in the front lines not just like
cooking in the Army go to wall basically
yeah go to war would you still want to
vote no yeah
no no no no no
hell no
I'm learning to cook anyway yeah
get me off of the battlefield
do you guys think the wage Gap exists no
it does does it does but it's only what
I don't know eight nine percent but are
you taking into account the time the
amount of time that women are out of
work and the amount of women that work
part-time the majority of men like they
they work full time and they work for a
lot longer than us so the statistics are
saying that there's a wage Gap generally
doesn't make any sense unless you
specify it down to women who are working
full-time and men who are working
full-time because otherwise the
statistics are skewed because
obviously there's going to be a gap in
the wages if a woman is working
part-time and a man is working full-time
and say a woman takes time out to go on
maternity leave or whatever like
I think that statistic is just silly
like if you look at men and women
actually in the same job like my job for
example
guy same age as me both graduates we
earn the same I don't I don't think you
ever walk into a job and the boss
decides she's gonna earn less because
she's a girl I think
maybe there might be a bit of bias when
employing someone do I want to hire say
a 28 year old who's just gotten married
versus say a 35 year old man if I was
the boss you know thinking financially I
would probably pick the man because okay
she's just got married she's 28 she's
not got much time left she's probably
gonna have kids soon and you have to pay
for a mature all right yeah you have to
pay for like thinking of that from an
employer perspective I gotta pay for you
did not work for six months no I agree
completely yeah and that's the thing
women don't want to do the most
stressful jobs typically and I say this
from like hiring people I've had
situations where I'll offer people roles
here where they'll make like double
triple the amount like but they'd have
to recruit and recruiting's hard and
they don't typically want to do it
and it's stressful because we can't do
the show if you don't do it
but women I don't know they just don't
want to do those jobs exactly and like
if you look at jobs like for example
like labor jobs I mean I don't know a
lot about this
um but you know the majority of women on
in labor jobs and people love to scream
oh this is inequality and you know women
aren't welcome in these industries now
be real with yourself do you actually
want to be on a construction site and
the majority of women don't want to be
there so that's why we're not there does
that means that's actually true you're
just going to teach yourself if that
means there would be a gap in the
working industry with man and woman a
wage Gap how would there be a wage Gap
because if a woman got employed in the
labor job same as a man she would still
earn the same so there wouldn't be a
wage she wouldn't earn the same because
she wouldn't be able to do the job
anyway she's not physically strong
enough to do the job and the boss will
see that so he's not going to pay
someone full wage knowing that she can't
even partake the full job anyway she's
not doing the same work as the guy
anyway so it's not inequality she's not
capable of doing what the man's capable
it would be really unfair to pay her the
same and a man break is about every day
and her get the same money I'll be livid
if my husband come home and as a woman
doing less and he's becoming unbroken
and like that's just not right yeah no
fair enough I mean I just think like
you usually hear things of people saying
like you know um I went on a podcast
recently and we were discussing
engineering and I was on there with a
girl who was talking about how she was
in engineering and she was really
successful in it like she was actually
like above the majority of men she was
in quite a high power position she she
struggled in that position obviously
because getting a group of men to listen
to you when you're in in an industry
like that is going to be quite hard
um but I just think like
women the majority of the times aren't
in those jobs because they don't want to
be like obviously physical strength is a
limitation of course but I I do believe
that in this day and age if you want to
do something you can go and give it a go
and I think if a woman wanted to be in
the labor industry she would and could
and should go give it a go I do agree
that well I'll be honest I'm a build
fiber engineer so
I'm the one that's picking up the Dark
Side of everything and pushing through
cables and everything bringing fiber to
people's and do you earn the same as
your yeah I own exactly the same so I I
want to ask a question would you guys
work in an oil rig in Alaska for three
hundred thousand dollars a year raise
your hand if you would yeah I would I
would it's all right
purely for curiosity
an adventure but that's what I mean if
you ask a group of guy that guys that
questions half of them are like I'm gone
you know they're going for the piece
like to get out the crazy households
that exist now like yes please
foreign
do you think women are more masculine
today than 50 years ago definitely 100
and have you guys ever struggled with
your femininity
[Laughter]
um okay someone anyway who struggled
with their feminine I would say I
struggled